- This is Yudkin
(bell dinging)
and this is probably
the most in-depth piece
of content you'll see from me this year.
In Colorado, shit got
deep with me and D-Rock,
hope you enjoy.
(lively music)
I think the world like, lacks optimism.
I think, you know, everyone's like,
"Your energy! Your energy!"
I've come to realize, it's just optimism.
Just happy, just positive.
That's what it is.
Like, whatever chemicals
are in my body, they just
allow me to see the bright
side, like and I just,
don't think I've realized
how few people have that.
Like, very few people have
it as black and white, 100-0.
I just think everything's good,
but like you know, I'm dying to know,
out of eight billion people,
like, what the breakdown is.
Like, my gut is like six
billion just go directly
into having more pessimism
and cynicism and negativity,
like 51-49 minimumly, all the
way down to very scary places.
I just don't think there's
a lot of 80% optimism
- [Man] Is that the way
they were raised, or?
- Just environment,
raised, all that stuff.
Anyway.
(sighs)
What's up Jesse Gomez, good
to see you, Coach John Castro,
great to see you.
Much love to all of you guys.
And, appreciate you so much.
"I force myself to become
optimistic every day, it does not
"come naturally," I get it Susan.
It doesn't come naturally
to a lot of people, I think
it's like, you know, if I
was able to say I'm lucky
about something, forget
about the business results,
it's lucky that, that optimism
comes naturally to me.
Like, I'm just optimistic,
like I just think that
so much works for me,
because I refuse to accept
the negative.
Like, you know, and I don't think...
I hate when people say it's, you know,
it's an option, or it's a choice.
I agree with you, Susan, I
don't think it comes naturally
to everybody, I think we're just starting
on the early stages of really
looking at mental health,
the brain, meditation,
and I do think, like,
that's like saying, be beautiful!
It doesn't come natural
to everybody, some of us,
you know, yes.
I'm just kidding.
But like, you know, like, I
, know you, I do think that
some things are etched with us early on,
and I'm so grateful, I sit
here in front of the 2000
of you, which in itself is
ridiculous, like I can turn
something on, and in three
minutes I have 2000 people,
care enough to hear what I have to say.
I sit here with, ego, and
humility, gratitude, and focus.
Appreciation, and a
sense of responsibility,
all built around, really
this optimistic foundation,
that is the fuel that
drives me to my hustle,
and to my execution in the
marketplace, and I thank you
for your, I thank you for your
for your attention and support,
and I recognize, you know
it's funny, like, I wish
people understood what I do
with my attention, you know,
somebody would just announce
VaynerSports, and somebody
wrote a cynical article here,
saying, "After watching the
announcement of VaynerSports,
"it's obvious to me that
Gary Vaynerchuk loves
"to hear himself speak."
Which is true, but what I'd
like to say to that journalist,
unnamed, you know, who writes
headlines to make pennies
in banner-ad advertising,
is, "My intent is a fuckload
"better than yours, partner."
What I want to do with
my attention is allow
the 2000 of you to 10s of 1000s of you,
to take it, I want to hand
you my optimism, my happiness,
my view of the world, my
opportunities that I see
in the white space, and
I want to give it to you,
for free, and then I want you to win.
And what I ask for in return
is the hope that I get
an email or the attention
for you to say thank you.
I have no interest in
monetizing anybody, and I think
people are basic.
They haven't figured me out.
They have just not figured it out.
I get off on people being grateful to me,
the way I'm grateful to
my mother, and father.
So, what you do with your
attention is very important,
and I implore all of you to
think about people that you're
spending time, and allowing
to have your attention,
what is their intent?
Have you been able to reverse engineer
what they want to happen?
Are they looking to
bring you into a funnel?
Into a master class?
Into an ebook, into a course?
Are they looking for you
to invest in their company?
Are they looking for you,
like what do they want?
What do they want?
Or, like many people, I'm
not on an island by myself,
are they just grateful
to get their craft out
into the world, and see
it live, and in scale.
Have you found the people
in your life that have
already won and are good?
'Cause that's what I am,
that's why I'm so attracted
to my mom, she's good.
She doesn't need anything.
I'm good, I don't need
anything from you guys.
I just don't need anything from you guys.
I don't want anything.
I want you to listen, and
then go have happiness
and success.
Whether that's work/life
balance, whether that's
honing your skiing skills,
whether that building
a million dollar business, I don't care.
I don't need you to be a hustler.
I don't need you to be an entrepreneur.
I don't need you to be a businessman.
I don't need you to do anything.
I need you to pay me back by
going out and doing something
with what I'm giving you,
paying back the attention
I'm taking, from you,
paying yourself back,
you know, giving me the
feeling that I'm bringing value
to the world, by actually doing something
about what I have to say.
That's what I'm doing with my
attention, what are you doing
with your attention?
Anyway, back to you guys, got
into a little rant mode there,
"Off to work, great job,"
Frances, I love that.
"That's Buddhist belief,
treat others as you would
"like to treat your mother."
I believe in that stuff,
whatever religion or genre,
or practice or thesis believes
in doing the right thing,
and doing right by others, and
then the universe takes over
and brings you value, I
actually think its not some,
karma cosmic thing, I think
it's actually quite practical.
Would it not make sense
to our practical brains,
that if you're doing something
good for somebody else,
that that puts you in a leverage position
for something good to happen to you.
I'm actually not very
romantic or cosmic, or spacey,
or zenified around providing people value.
Like, I love karma, I believe
in it, 'cause I believe
karma's fucking practical.
How about that?
Because I believe karma's practical.
I believe that if you do
something good for somebody else,
if you provide them value,
if you're taking their time
and providing them with good
thoughts, and good themes,
and good strategies, and good outlooks,
and seeing white space.
I believe that the people
that started SnapChat,
design agencies building filters,
oh, I broke out.
I believe that the people that went out
and built SnapChat design
filter agencies that have been
making money over the last
month, because they listened
to me, yeah, I believe that
they'll say good things
about me, that will make
more people pay attention.
I believe that they'll tell
clients to work with me.
their sister that's talented
or their brother that's
talented to go work for Vaynor,
or intern there.
Yes I do believe that doing
the right thing is practical.
I love it.
"How do you deal with
low energy or sickness?"
Dave, when you're sick, you
gotta get rest, and you gotta
get better, you write.
But low energy doesn't come natural to me.
I've realized what's
going on here, one life.
I've realized that I'm
living like, this is our only
at-bat, and most of you aren't.
People are fucking walking around here,
like they're coming back.
People fucking walking around
here like they're coming back!
(laughs)
You're not coming back.
Well, listen, I don't want to
impose my beliefs on others,
maybe you believe you're coming back.
I believe if you're coming
back, you're coming back
as a tree, or as a flower
pot, or D-Rock's sneakers.
And that blows compared to being a human,
and so I'm acting that way.
I'm acting that way.
(thoughtful music)